NINA: Thank you all for coming.
My name is Nina.
And today we have Rohan Dixit to
present Engineering Calm Sensor
Driven Meditation technology
as part of the Talks
at Google series brought
to you by gPause,
a community of
mindfulness practices
for well being change at Google.
The last 10 years have
seen the growing acceptance
of mindfulness meditation
in mainstream science.
Hundreds of studies
have now demonstrated
quantifiable physiological
effects of meditation
on heart rhythms, stress,
immune response, and more.
In fact, it appears
the brain itself
changes both during
the act of meditation,
as well as after
repeated practice.
We'll show you the
brainwave, heartbeat,
and breath sensors
that can help you track
your mind during your day.
For example, breathing patterns
are correlated with stress.
And, in fact, many
forms of meditation
encourage watching
of the breath.
A wearable respiration sensor
that gives you feedback
when you're stressed can
be imagined as a technology
assisted meditation practice.
The coming ubiquity
of wearable sensors
make opportunities
for calm engineering
like this potentially
quite common.
We'll show you the state
of the field today.
Rohan Dixit is a
founder at BrainBot
and a former
neuroimaging researcher
at the Harvard MIT MGH Martino
Center and Stanford University.
In a search for the ultimate
meaning of life, the universe,
and everything,
Rohan quit his job
and bought a one-way
ticket to the Himalayas
where he lived with
Tibetan monks for a year
and recorded their brain
waves during meditation.
This eventually led
to a meditation app
that uses a brain waves sensor
as well as a flower that blooms
with your calm brain waves.
This summer and
fall, Rohan will be
creating a variety of
large art installations
that react to your
relaxed heartbeat,
including a garden,
a 15 feet tall metal
lotuses, and huge
murals that encourage
heart syncing between people.
I'm thrilled to
present to you today
my former classmate and dear
friend of 10 years, Rohan.
[APPLAUSE]
ROHAN DIXIT: As Nina was
saying, my name is Rohan.
And I'm the founder of BrainBot,
which is a group of three
or four friends who are all
interested in the intersection
between meditation and censors.
So it's kind of an
interesting space.
You can imagine that sensors
are something that's pretty new,
especially wearable
sensors, whereas meditation
is something that's pretty
ancient and pretty old.
So it's an interesting
kind of intersection
to be playing with.
And I want to talk a little
bit about the companies that
are in the space now, the
sensors that are already
out there, and a little bit
about what we're working on
now.
I'll try to keep it
short so that we have
a lot of time for questions.
So like Nina was
saying, my background
is actually in neuroimaging.
And I started kind of
studying the C-word.
So the C-word in neuroscience
is Consciousness, actually.
And it's been hard
for many years--
actually, decades-- to
study consciousness.
It's kind of a taboo
subject, right?
So the way that we do that
in the clinical context
and in neuroscience
in general is
to study things that
are very, very concrete.
Alterations in consciousness
like, for example,
people in a coma.
You can imagine that
somebody in a coma
has some degree
of consciousness.
You can poke them
or have some kind
of basic reflexes still intact.
But their consciousness, their
sort of awareness on some level
is gone.
So that's kind of a
window, an insight,
into what consciousness is.
So we study people
who are in comas.
We've studied people who were
under deep anesthesia, which
is a similar kind of situation.
We have people who had
epilepsy-- temporal lobe
epilepsy-- and they tend to have
altered states of consciousness
during their seizures.
So those are three
kind of short examples
of ways of studying
consciousness
that exist already in
the neuroscience world.
But eventually I ended up in
Sara Lazar's lab at Harvard
studying people who
meditate and their brain.
And so you can see
here on the screen
this is a monk who has a whole
bunch of sensors on his head.
Those are called EEG sensors or
electroencephalography sensors.
And basically what
they're doing is
measuring the
electrical activity
of the brain in real time
while the monk does things.
So you can imagine asking
the monk to meditate
and recording the brain
waves before and after
and seeing what changes
actually happen.
And it turns out that
the brain actually
does change during meditation.
Both over the short term
and kind of the long term.
So with these sensors,
you're able to pick up
on these changes that are
happening structurally and also
the changes that are
happening in real time.
So why is it that you might
want to study meditation?
Meditation is kind of
a hokey thing, right?
It's kind of a woo-woo
or magical in a way.
But the practices themselves
are actually quite simple
and really kind of boil down to
attentional training and self
inquiry in a way.
So meditation often is
associated with the East,
but I think this is kind
of an ancient trend.
The idea of self
knowledge and self inquiry
was something that
Socrates was really into.
Know thyself.
And I think that's the basis
for a lot of forms of therapy
as well today.
Kind of having self awareness
I think is how all of us
kind of grow as people.
The ability to
introspect into yourself,
to see yourself in
different situations,
and to understand how you
react to stressors in the world
actually allows you to grow.
And meditation actually
in part is that.
It's building the ability
to kind of look inwards,
to see your own body,
to see your own mind,
and to watch yourself
with sustained attention
over the course of your life.
So it turns out that just
like any other practice,
for example, learning
juggling, if you
look at people who
learn juggling over
the course of three
to eight weeks
you kind of see
that there are areas
in the brain like in the motor
cortex that actually thicken.
That is just called
neuroplasticity.
It just seems be the case
that the brain actually
responds and grows in response
to repeated activities.
The same thing is
true with meditation.
And so what we were
doing in the lab
was basically studying that.
Trying to characterize how the
brain is actually changing.
We found a lot of
interesting things.
For example, it appears that
in as little as eight weeks
you can have measurable
changes in the brain in areas
that are associated with sense
of self and also empathy.
Those are two aspects
of personality
that oftentimes are interesting
to play with and to develop.
So that was my life as
a researcher in a lab.
And I love it.
I love research.
And I'm kind of a nerd about it.
But I found myself as we
were studying meditation
realizing that it was actually
a pretty beneficial thing.
It seemed like the monks in
the long term meditation study
tended to be happier
people, just more relaxed.
And I kind of wanted
that for myself,
although I didn't
really feel it.
So I decided eventually
to follow those monks
that we were studying
in the lab back
to the Himalayas
where they lived
to try to understand what
meditation actually was
and to do it for myself.
And because I am a nerd, I took
a bunch of brain wave equipment
with me to try to
measure their brains.
I thought I could
make a device that
would help me learn to
meditate without any
of the kind of
interface of words.
When you try to explain how
to do something to somebody
you can only use words to
really describe what you mean.
But the advantage
of using sensors
is that you can
actually map what's
happening in someone's body to
what's happening in your body
without the crutch of language.
So that was the idea.
I took a bunch of brain
wave sensors with me.
And I spent, as Nina was
saying, almost a year
traveling around through India
going to these monasteries that
are at the top of the Himalayan
mountains and meeting theses
monks.
These monks are really
interesting people.
I could probably tell you
stories for days about them.
But what kind of
came out of that was,
one, a deeper sense
for myself personally
of just what meditation was
and what it could do to you.
These people are really, really
nice and really friendly.
And I think some of that stems
in part from their practices.
And, two, it kind
of led to this app.
So when I came back from India,
some friends and I were kind
of looking at the data and we
realized that with a little bit
of machine learning you can kind
of pick out when somebody is
meditating and
when they weren't.
So we sort of applied the state
of the art in neuroscience
with a little bit
of machine learning
to basically interface with a
commercially available headset.
This thing is about $100.
It's the NeuroSky.
And help people
learn to meditate
with a virtual
meditation instructor.
So this app is in
the Apple App Store.
I felt a little bit embarrassed
not having an Android app
coming to Google.
But soon hopefully.
And it kind of does
some interesting things.
So one of them is
just habit design,
which is really boring and
simple, but actually really
important.
I don't know if any of you
have tried to meditate.
I've tried and
failed so many times.
It's out of control.
And part of that is just
the ability to build a habit
and to do it repeatedly.
So some of what the
app does is just
simple kind of like this flower,
this plant grows in real time.
And your goal is to kind of
keep it alive like a Tamagotchi.
I don't know if you guys are
old enough or young enough
to remember what that is.
But basically it's
like a little device
that you keep in your pocket.
And it was like a
little creature.
You had to feed it and make
sure it was healthy and happy.
And so this is kind
of the same idea.
This is a plant you keep
alive with your meditation.
One of the cool
things that we were
able to build in with
the brain wave sensor
was this kind of
realtime feedback--
the virtual mediation
instructor I was talking about.
So in real time we're kind of
looking at your brain waves
and we're analyzing them.
And when the app kind of
detects that your mind starts
to wander, it actually can give
you a short feedback queue.
So this is a fun kind of example
of how that might happen.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Notice what's happening.
Relax and gently reconnect
with your breath.
[END PLAYBACK]
ROHAN DIXIT: So what you
can see there is essentially
real time neuro
feedback, guiding
somebody through a meditation.
You can do that through sensors.
And it's just one example
of what you can kind of do.
And this is another project
that we're working on.
You can actually
pre-order this now.
It's called the Lotus.
It's kind of very similar to
the app in that it is a plant.
It's a flower that grows.
But this is a physical thing.
Some friends and I just kind
of hacked it together for fun.
But basically the
idea is that it acts
as a meditation Pomodoro timer.
I don't know if you guys
have ever played with this.
But essentially Pomodoro timer
is kind of just an egg timer.
You set it for, say, 30
minutes or 20 minutes.
You start to work at
your desk, and when
the timer goes off it's
time to take a break
or do something else.
So this is very similar idea.
But it's actually
a flower and it's
integrated with biosensors.
So the way that it works is
as you start to meditate,
the flower picks
up the meditation
through the headset via
Bluetooth and blooms.
So here's a little animation
of how that happens.
[CHIMES FROM VIDEO]
You see the headset.
It's sending data to your phone.
And your phone is then
analyzing and determining
when you're meditating and
using that as a signal to bloom
this physical flower
that sits on your desk.
Over time that flower
starts to close again,
and that just acts as
a reminder to meditate.
So that's another kind of
fun project you can do.
It's very simple now
with these sensors
and with a little bit
of a single processing.
So I wanted to talk a little bit
about some of the sensors that
are out there.
We're talking about
engineering calm and sensor
driven meditation technology.
So I wanted to introduce
you to some of the, I think,
cutting edge and best
in class sensors that
are out there today.
So this sensor is
called the Spire.
You can pre-order
it I believe now.
And they should start
shipping in the fall.
But the Spire is basically
a respiration sensor.
So essentially what it does is
it kind of clips into your belt
or into your bra, and
there's a little flex sensor
kind of built inside.
And as you breathe the
Spire recognizes that you're
breathing and kind of
analyzes that on your phone,
and gives you a feedback
signal and determines
that your breathing
pattern seems stressed out.
So you can imagine that
your body is all connected.
Your brain, your
heart, your breath.
These things are all
intimately linked in some way.
And so almost like
a hologram, if you
look at any piece of your
body or any kind of aspect,
any biosignal, you can see
reflections of other signals,
as well.
And so by analyzing the
breath, the people at Spire
have been able to find
a way to sort of get
at when you're stressed out and
the phone kind of buzzes you
when it determines that you're
either holding your breath
or the breath is
sort of indicative of
a stressed or frustrated state.
We actually hooked
this up to the Lotus
a couple weeks ago at a
consciousness hacking meeting,
which is meet up that
happens in San Francisco
about every month.
And this is the emWave.
So we just talked
about the breath.
The Spire looks at respiration.
The emWave is a product that's
been around for about 10 years.
And I think it's
probably the best
kind of heart rate
or heart derived
meditation device out there.
So I just want to kind of
talk you through how it works.
You can kind of see based
on the screen there's
like a little box and a clip.
That clip essentially
goes on to your ear lobe.
And what it's doing
is measuring your HRV.
So your HRV is Heart
Rate Variability.
It's a signal that's embedded
inside of your heart rhythm.
It's kind of an
interesting thing.
And you can probably kind of
test this as you sit here.
When you're relatively
relaxed and you breathe in,
your heartbeat actually goes up.
People often have this
idea that your heartbeat
is pretty stable.
It's actually not true.
Your heartbeat is constantly
kind of going up and down.
And the way that it works is
on inhale your heartbeat rises
a little bit.
You can kind of test, right?
And on exhale your heart
beat kind of drops.
So if you graph that over
time, what you're seeing
is basically on an inhale your
heartbeat goes up and an exhale
it goes down.
And that kind of
sinusoidal rhythm
is what the emWave uses
to give you feedback
as to when you're relaxed.
If you're not very
relaxed or you're
kind of frustrated or
tense, you're not actually
able to elicit that sinusoidal
wave when you breath in
and breath out.
The way that the
emWave does that
is with a series of LEDs that
are on the side of this device.
Basically as you breath in, the
LEDs go up, as you breath in,
they go down.
And you just kind of look
at that and try to relax,
elicit that wave, which,
of course, is correlated
with your body actually
feeling less tense,
less stressed, and relaxed.
So we kind of
riffed on that idea,
the idea of heart
rate variability
or this kind of stress
signal inside of the heart
beat in this big installation
we're doing over the summer.
So this is happening
at Burning Man.
We got a grant from them to
do a big art installation.
As Nina was saying,
there are these kind
of these 15 foot tall lotuses.
And this is a mockup
and a rendering.
We're building it now
out in American Steel.
If anybody wants to help, you're
more than welcome to swing by.
But basically the way that
this installation works
is by measuring people's HRV,
or Heart Rate Variability,
that kind of breathing
in and breathing out
signal of relaxation and
kind of correlating that
to the brightness of
a 15 foot tall Lotus
in the middle of the desert.
Now, it's not just one.
Like with the emWave
it's a single device.
But the way that
this works is more
of an interactive,
collaborative thing.
So why would you want to have
the HRV measured, the Heart
Rate Variability measured for
different people in a group
setting?
It turns out there was
some research in 2013
that came out of UC Davis.
It was really interesting.
So I read this and I got
of course very excited
because I'm a nerd
and I get excited
about this kind of stuff.
And what it kind of
showed was that people
who are in a long term
relationship for a year
or more, if you put them
across from their partner
and just kind of have them stare
into their partner's eyes--
no talking allowed
for three minutes.
It's kind of a long time.
It's kind of crazy,
but if you're
measuring their heart rate,
they actually start to sync up.
The Heart Rate Variability
of both of these people
starts to align and sync.
And if you switch
that out to somebody
in the waiting room who is a
member of another couple-- so
two strangers-- that
syncing doesn't happen.
So the interpretation
that the researchers had
was that the ability to
empathize with someone
allows you to somehow have these
subconscious cues that actually
lets you sync with other people.
And so this art
installation is kind
of an experiment in empathy.
Basically the idea is
the state of empathy
seems to allow you to sync.
So what happens if we
measure that syncing process,
give you visual feedback
almost mechanically,
and draw your body into
that state of syncing?
Do you then kind of have that
reverse mapping take place
where you then feel empathetic
towards other people.
It turns out that your body
and your mind are very linked.
So if you force yourself into
a certain physiological state,
oftentimes the mental
state is connected.
And so that's the idea
of the installation.
We're kind of riffing on that
as well in India over the fall.
So basically this is another
big installation, a mural,
that we're going to
do in Dharamsala,
which is where the Dalai
Lama lives in India, and also
in Bombay, which is a huge
city, a bustling metropolis.
And the idea here is
also very similar.
You can see on the
screen it says,
"There is a path from
your heart to mind,"
which is a Rumi quote.
I'm working on this installation
with a really talented artist
named Shilo Shiv Suleman,
who is actually Indian.
And the idea is
basically to allow people
to sync in a public space.
It's kind of all based around
the idea of sacred spaces
in India, which are
often very public.
And we're kind of
bringing that back
with a little bit of technology.
So the idea is you touch
an illuminated hand that's
kind of set against the wall.
And there's actually
a sensor embedded
in one of the fingertips.
And that sensor measures your
heart rate and your Heart Rate
Variability.
So as you start to
relax and breath deeply,
the entire wall comes
alive with LEDs and lights.
And there's a message that
says, find another partner,
and another hand that becomes
illuminated across from you.
So then you have to find
somebody walking down
the street, they have to put
their hand against the wall.
They have to breath deeply.
When both of you do that
together and the syncing sort
of happens, then a
hidden message comes out.
For example, there's a path
from your heart to mind.
It's a fun little
project, but it
is kind of indicative
of the ability
to very quickly use
sensors and a little bit
of signal processing to make
an interactive experience that
allows people to engender
hopefully empathy.
So we've talked about a couple
devices and a couple art
projects and just general ideas
around meditation and sensors.
And this is something
that I think about a lot.
The idea is, at
least in my own mind,
to find some sort of device
that I can wear that allows me
all the time in real time
almost ambiently to be aware
of my own stress levels and to
respond to that appropriately.
So what you need
there is then a sensor
and you need feedback
of some type.
So that feedback
could be visual,
like the HeartMath, that
device with the LEDs
that go up and down.
You kind of have to
look at the thing.
You see it's measuring your
heart rate and your Heart Rate
Variability, and you watch
as the LEDs go up and down.
And that's visual feedback.
But there are all kinds of
feedback that you could use.
You can imagine
auditory feedback.
We played with that, as well.
We kind of mocked
together a little sensor
that goes behind your ear
and kind of beeps at you
all the time when it
recognizes your heart beating.
That's also not very ambient.
And it's not very
wearable, right?
The ideal device
that kind of does
is, the ideal meditation
technology is probably
totally invisible, it's
socially acceptable,
and it's wearable
throughout the day.
And so with those as
design kind of parameters,
we have wrestled a lot
with how to actually make
this thing work.
And this is something
that we just started
working on like a week ago.
I wanted to show you guys
and get a little feedback.
It's a little weird but
basically we have these sensors
and we're like, OK, where on the
body can we measure the signal?
So what we're
measuring now is HRV.
It's a very easy
to pick up signal,
much more so than these
brainwave sensors.
And so we were trying to figure
out exactly how to measure it.
We looked at the wrist.
That turned out to be difficult
for different reasons.
It's hard to get a clean
signal from the wrist,
as any of you who bought a
Basis watch probably know.
It's actually not a
trivial thing to do.
I think Google Wear and there's
a whole bunch of other sensors
that are on the wrist.
We tried basically
all parts of the body.
It was pretty ridiculous
seeing us kind of pace
these sensors all
over the place.
But this is a process of
trying to find something
in the a space
where you don't know
what the answer is beforehand.
And then, eventually--
I apologize.
This is my friend, Luke.
He likes to take his
shirt off, god bless him.
But this is actually a photo
that we took yesterday.
And so we kind of, as I
said, just came up with this.
This is essentially
a belt or strap
that you wear underneath
your clothing.
And it's totally invisible.
And you can kind of
see up in the top right
that's a diagram for
a patent application
that we are submitting.
And you can kind of
see it on his chest.
There's a whole bunch of
different vibrating sensors
across a strap that
kind of looks like this.
And so what happens is as your
HRV starts to kind of relax--
and, again, just to
reiterate one more
time what HRV is because it's a
kind of a hard concept to grok.
So what you're seeing
in this illustration
is basically a time
series in the lower
right of heart rate over time.
And you can see that
it's kind of going
up and down a little bit.
That was me walking
down the street.
And then you can see me start
to breathe deeply and relax
and you can see how kind of the
rhythms start to get really,
really sinusoidal and larger.
So that large sinusoidal
rhythm, that's HRV.
That's you being relaxed.
And if you don't see
that, then you're
probably not feeling super calm.
So essentially what we did
was map that to an array
of vibrating sensors.
Similar to the way that
you look at the HeartMath
and kind of see the
LEDs go up and down,
basically the central
sensor in the middle kind of
buzzes when you're at the
valley of this HRV rhythm.
And as you inhale and
your HRV increases,
the vibrating array comes alive.
And kind of the feedback
extends across the entire band.
And as you stop with your
breath and start to exhale,
it comes back down.
So what you get is what we
call this hummingbird pattern
where basically as you
inhale and you're relaxed,
you feel on your chest
sort of this opening
and closing of vibration.
It's totally ambient.
It's totally hidden.
And nobody knows
you're wearing it.
But what it does
allow you to do is
kind of be a little more
relaxed throughout the day.
This is the kind
of design process
that we have been going
through to find a device that
allows you to basically have
meditation wearable wherever
you go.
And so I just wanted to
show you very quickly.
I think some of you may
have seen this already.
But I just want to show
you a little bit of what
this wave looks
like and hopefully
a little demonstration
to close it out.
So I'm a little
bit nervous, right?
I'm giving a talk in
front of a lot of people.
And I tried to prepare for it.
Maybe didn't do
enough preparation.
Maybe this isn't
going as well I hope.
You have all kinds of thoughts.
All kinds of fears no
matter what you're doing.
You always have doubts, right?
So you can kind of see that
reflected in the heart rate.
That's pretty fast.
That's a pretty high heart rate.
And you can kind of see if
you just kind of look at it,
every one of those
spikes is a heart beat.
I'm wearing some sensors under
my clothes which of course you
can't see because
it's invisible.
But this is my
heart in real time.
So what I'm going to try to do
if you guys will bear with me
is try to elicit a little bit of
HRV by relaxing in front of you
on stage.
So what will that look like?
What you should
see is that there
will be a period of
heart beats which
will start to be kind of
condensed faster, that's
my inhale.
Because as you breathe in,
everyone's body-- yours, mine,
everyone's-- your heart
rate starts to increase.
And as you exhale your
heartbeat starts to decrease.
So on my exhale you should
see those spikes start
to get a little bit
further apart, right?
So let's do this.
[BREATHING]
So I don't know if that
was too subtle to see
or if I couldn't
relax, but that's
like a pretty good
example of how
you can use this thing in
real time in your real life.
Because there are always
situations often scattered
throughout the
day where you have
to talk to your boss or you
have to talk to your girlfriend.
So there are situations where
perhaps your stress level
will be higher than normal.
It happens in every human
relationship, right?
And so to have the ability to
recognize when your body is
getting stressed out and to
actually gain control of that
is actually a really
important skill,
because it allows
you to then face
the relationships in
your life and your world
in general with more calmness
and a little bit more empathy.
So that's the idea behind
all of these sensors
and that's the goal of this
vibrating strap and the Spire
and HeartMath and all
these devices that
are in this space of
engineering calm and sensor
driven meditation.
So I kind of want to let
this run in the background
and just take some
questions from you guys
if anybody has any.
AUDIENCE: I was wondering how
far do you think we can go
and what do you think is the
direction which it might appear
to be available in terms of
providing feedback to people
that it becomes basically
something they're not aware of.
I mean, something that is
just so physical they actually
get to totally built into
the whole biofeedback loop.
ROHAN DIXIT: Yeah.
So you used the
word biofeedback.
And that's actually
what this is.
Its biofeedback.
So for anybody
who's not familiar,
biofeedback is
basically when you
start to feedback to yourself
one of your own body signals,
you tend to gain
control over it.
So that's kind of a weird
thing to say, but in the '70s--
this is when this
research kind of started--
they used biofeedback on
college students who would
come into the research lab.
So basically what they did was
put a little temperature sensor
on their finger and tell
these college kids--
like 19-20-year-olds--
to raise the temperature
of their finger,
which is impossible.
How can you do that?
But it turns out that if you are
actually monitoring that signal
and you're seeing
it in real time
or feeling it across
your chest, you actually
gain the ability over time
to move that signal yourself.
This is the crux of
biofeedback and why
this is actually potentially
such a powerful space.
So eventually what
you're able to do
is gain conscious
control of something
was totally unconscious before.
So in the case of
the finger tip,
it's the ability to raise
your finger temperature.
Not that useful.
Kind of a cool party
trick maybe if you
have a thermometer around.
But in the case
of a signal that's
correlated with your stress,
with your inner state,
if you gain control
over that, then you
gain the ability to
move throughout your day
and throughout your
world in a way that
is much more calm and much more
open to what's happening around
you without getting
stressed out.
And so my hope is
with all these devices
after you wear it for a
little while you kind of gain
this ability to
control the process.
And hopefully like training
wheels you just drop them.
The idea is that you
should be able to gain
biofeedbacked control over
this by kind of feedbacking,
if that is a word, these
sensors into your own body
through your sensory
stream and then drop it.
You won't need it anymore.
That's the hope.
AUDIENCE: I'm curious
of your opinion, what
are the various advantages and
disadvantages of monitoring
the heart compared to the brain?
ROHAN DIXIT: Yeah.
Like I said, I started
with neuroscience.
And we actually started
with an EEG device,
which is really cool.
And we do have a
product out there
that does EEG based feedback.
But the problem with EEG is that
you can't wear it all the time
really.
The signal itself
is very, very weak.
It's very difficult to detect.
And then any kind of movement,
like an eye blink, for example,
just washes out
the signal totally.
So realistically, in
the next couple years,
you're not going to
have a device you
can wear on your head that
gives you this kind of feedback
into your own mind that allows
you to do neuro feedback
or biofeedback through the head.
Also it's kind of weird.
I don't know if people
have kind of run
into this with Google
Glass to a degree,
but there's some social stigma.
Whether that's justified or
not is irrelevant at least
from our perspective.
But there is a little
bit of hesitation
around wearing
something on your head
and it's very
visible, especially
if it's kind of like helping
you deal with anxiety or stress
or that sort of thing.
And so we shifted to the
heart because the rhythm
itself is much easier to detect.
It's been studied
for like 60 years.
HRV is easy to
pick up relatively.
Coming from an EEG background,
this is just awesome.
And you can measure it
from under your clothes.
And so I think
eventually hopefully
these devices kind actually
become part of our clothing.
And I think that's
where it's going.
But at least in
the short term, we
are focusing on the heart signal
because it's easier to measure.
You can measure it from
places that are unobtrusive
and it's just much
more well understood.
AUDIENCE: You know
a bit about-- I'm
actually interested not
just in meditation but I'm
interested in trying
to figure out how
to be able to manipulate focus.
So obviously as a
software engineer
that's really
important in what I do.
And there are times
during the day when I find
it very difficult to focus.
And I'm trying to get an answer
of can I measure when either I
shouldn't focus now.
I should go to the
gym and come back.
Or whether I can
actually get myself
into a mind frame
of focus where I
can get things done quickly
and efficiently and correctly.
And I think meditation
is a part of this,
but one of the things I have
difficulty distinguishing
is that my heart isn't moving
that much because I'm just
exhausted.
And my brain isn't
actually moving either.
And so that's sort of a state
of meditation maybe even focus,
but not moving forward
in terms of computing.
And what I'd like
to do, as well,
is come up with
something, a practice
that helps me in my work in
addition to just being calm.
And I'm curious whether or
not you see any distinction
between that and meditation.
Whether there's
some other signals
that might be worth looking for
in terms of building something
to help focus.
ROHAN DIXIT: That's
very interesting.
Yeah.
So meditation is a
pretty big catchall word.
It includes practices
that let you relax,
but also practices that
build your attention.
And focus is another word
for attention, perhaps.
It's tough.
I mean, EEG is really the way to
go I think for building focus,
in general.
This is more sort of
relaxation in general
and allowing yourself
to not be anxious.
Yeah.
So in terms of building
your own ability to focus,
I mean this is probably
pretty common advice,
but people tend to have
patterns throughout the day.
For example, right after lunch
is oftentimes not a great time
to try to focus.
The human mind itself, you
probably have encountered this,
if you take a break from
programming for a while
or from any skill, you kind of
lose the ability to sustain it
over a long period of time.
And you build that back up.
It's just a skill
like any other.
So one way that might
be nice in terms
of finding our your rhythms
is just to track a little bit.
I don't know if you
already do this.
But even a simple
spreadsheet kind of help.
AUDIENCE: I've got a thing with
an app on my phone to do that.
But I was interested in
perhaps connecting that
with sensor data so
that I can basically
take that sensor data
for my own personal self,
be able to track
patterns in that,
and also connect it
with constant feedback
back to myself every hour
or so how are you feeling
and maybe train it that way.
ROHAN DIXIT: Yeah.
You could totally use
one of these EEG devices.
Like, for example, our
app Sunlight Meditation.
It's kind of a
session based thing.
You sit down.
You train your focus for
a certain amount of time
and then you take the thing off.
But it does give
you a ton of graphs
afterwards in terms of
what your attention was
over that period of time.
It tracks that over
days and weeks.
So you can actually start to
see some trends in that way.
And all that data is fully open,
so you can export it and slice
and dice it however you see fit.
That might be one thing to do.
AUDIENCE: I have a
question about whether you
have done any research for
using these kinds of devices
for people who have
depression or memory loss.
That meditation would help
them to getting better.
ROHAN DIXIT: Yes.
It's a good question.
So meditation does actually
provide-- at least in studies
that have been undertaken
thus far-- some resilience
to both anxiety and depression.
The mechanism for that is
not totally understood,
but it seems to be the case.
So if you're able to kind
of control your attention,
you kind of decide to a
degree what you think about.
And most people that
suffer from depression
suffer from this
ruminative loop.
This is what it's described
like in the literature.
Basically that's like a
very obscure and obtuse way
of describing just negative
thoughts that kind of run
through your head.
Negative self talk.
Everybody has that to a degree.
But oftentimes people that are
depressed can't turn it off.
And to a degree that's a
selective attention problem.
So if you can train
your attention
to focus on whatever
it is you like,
then you can probably
move your attention away
from those thoughts
and towards things
that are more positive
and beneficial to you.
So meditation, if
you think of it
in terms of
attentional training,
just builds your
attentional muscle.
So I think that is how
it does actually offer
some benefits with depression.
You also mentioned memory loss.
Memory is like a several
interacting subsystems
in the brain.
So I'm not an expert, so
I'm probably not the person
to talk to you about it.
But I think it is the case
that intentional training can
improve your short term memory.
So not to tout
meditation as a panacea,
but I think it
does actually help
to a degree with memory loss
and certainly with depression.
AUDIENCE: So do you know
the kind of research
done with people who
selected a group of people,
for example, with depression
with this training compared
with people who have not
been using this technology
to see the difference?
ROHAN DIXIT: Right.
I think there are probably
a dozen studies that
have looked at that
now in relatively
well controlled ways.
So usually what you
do is try to compare
people who learn mindfulness
usually through this course.
And most hospitals
now, there are maybe
450 hospitals at this
point around the country
that offer meditation
as training
for people with anxiety and
depression, also chronic pain.
And the way they do that
is through this course
called MBSR, or Mindfulness
Based Stress Reduction.
It's about an eight week course.
And it kind of guides you
through learning meditation.
And I think that has
been shown to be quite
efficacious with depression.
So, if you like, I
can get your email
and send you some of those
studies if that's helpful.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name is Alex.
And I missed the consciousness
hacking in San Francisco.
So I'm so excited to come today.
So I've been reading
your stuff since then.
And I was really
interested in that
because you studied with monks.
I was wondering what
your thoughts were
that is this almost a result
of contemporary society
that there's so much external
stimuli that we need a device
or that we need some
kind of hardware now,
some kind of biofeedback,
whereas for the past 5,000
years, monks were
able to do it just
through training the brain?
Like it's just
something I wasn't
quite able to form the
question like how I wanted,
but could you speak to that?
ROHAN DIXIT: Sure.
That's something I
think about a lot.
The amount of sensory
input we have on a day
to day basis in terms of
distractions is out of control.
Like it's probably never been
seen in human history before.
I mean checking your
email, Twitter, Facebook.
There's just
constant distraction.
And to a degree that's being
facilitated by technology.
So it's a little bit ironic
to use that same technology
kind of approach to get
you out of that loop.
Perhaps that's the way to do it.
I think in years
past probably people
were able to sustain
their attention
for longer periods of time.
And that's probably a factor
of having less input and less
distraction in general.
So I do feel that
technology now has a role
to play in bringing us back to
the ability to pay attention,
not only to things around
us in terms of focus,
but also to pay
attention to ourselves.
And I think that's where a
lot of self growth happens.
That's what I'm
really interested in
because that's where a lot of my
growth personally has happened.
AUDIENCE: So you
mentioned biofeedback.
Have you given any thought
to active direction
of the person using the device?
So, for example, there's
one device out there
I think it's called
Respirator which uses music.
And it slows down
the music in response
to where it thinks you're going.
But it sort of encourages
you to go there.
I don't know what
class of device
that is, but is that something
you're interested in?
ROHAN DIXIT: It is.
And, yeah, we have thought
about that a little bit.
So what you're doing basically
is guiding someone a little.
So over time as you're
listening to the music that's
being generated
by your breathing,
if I understand that
device correctly,
you're sort of building an
association between the music
and your state of mind.
At least your breathing
pattern, right?
So just like anything else, like
smells of your childhood say,
the ability to smell like fresh
baked chocolate chip cookies
can remind you of
mom instantaneously
and a whole suite of memories.
So if there's a
certain music that's
generated when your
breathing is calm
and then you play that music
back to somebody, most likely
you are able to shift
them into that state.
So by playing with
their current rhythm,
like this is my heart rhythm.
If I'm feeling it
vibrating against me,
say that's one of
the modes where
that we've built where
kind of the chest strap
constantly vibrates
at every heart beat.
It's not super useful, but it is
useful in the sense of guiding,
which is why I built it.
The idea would be my
heart rate is starting
to go up a little
bit, maybe too much,
and the sensor is
reading when my heart
beat is happening and
then sort of slowing it
down a little bit.
So the feedback that I'm used
to getting on every heartbeat
is delayed a slight amount.
And so I feel the
vibration as if I
had a slightly slower heart
beat than I really do,
which then guides me towards
a state of a slower heartbeat.
So there's a ton of interaction
I think that is possible there
through biofeedback.
And it's funny that it hasn't
really been explored much.
But I think that's partially
a factor biofeedback becoming
popular in the '70s, promising
a little too much too soon,
and not having the computing
power to really wear
these things around
with you, which is where
the true benefit I think comes.
You may be familiar with
these neuro feedback clinics
and biofeedback clinics.
They're all over the country.
You basically go to
an office, sit down
for like an hour and a half
once a week or once a month
and pay $100 or $500
or whatever and try
to gain some biofeedback
knowledge that way.
But I think now
that the devices are
much smaller and portable
a lot of these applications
may become pretty commonplace.
AUDIENCE: You say that people
in long term relationships
can synchronize
their heart rates.
I thought that was
really interesting.
And I was wondering if you know
the direction of the causality
there?
Do people who
spend a lot of time
together learn to
synchronize their hearts
or do people who are unable to
synchronize their hearts have
relationship trouble and break
up before a year has passed?
ROHAN DIXIT: That's
a fair point.
And I don't think
anyone knows the answer.
But what people did
notice in that study,
in particular, which I
guess is all I can speak to,
is that in general when they
looked at the sort of direction
between the couple in terms
of who was actually syncing
to the other, I
mean-- you can imagine
that there are sort of like
two metronomes happening--
and what they found
was that in general one
member of the couple tended
to sort of see or empathize
or perceive the
other's oscillation
and sync to them,
rather than them both
coming to some sort of
inbetween 50/50 sort of split.
And in general
what they found was
that the women in
the relationship
tended to be able
to do that to a much
greater degree than the men.
So that may have some kind of
insight into your question.
AUDIENCE: As a
follow up, are there
any other kinds of relationships
where this happens?
Like could you use
it to predict who
would make compatible co-workers
or astronauts on a mission
to Mars or something like that?
ROHAN DIXIT: I
think it's possible.
And the only time I've seen
this study before-- it's
a pretty recent phenomena
that hasn't really
been studied much-- was with
I believe family members.
This was a study out of Spain.
And people were doing this
fire walking exercise where
there was a bunch of coals
and one member of the family
jumps up and kind of
walks across the coals.
And what they found was that
members of their family,
even watching them
do that, tended
to synchronize with the
HRV of the person who
was doing the fire walk.
So it seems to be the case that
in any close relationship kind
elicits that.
But I think it's
too early to tell.
AUDIENCE: So going back
to studying the monks
and going into the meditation.
So how do you know that that's
correlated with brain signals
and not just relaxing the
forehead muscle or something?
ROHAN DIXIT: How do we know
that what is not correlated?
AUDIENCE: That going in to
meditation in the signal
that you saw off the
EEG is not correlated
with relaxing a muscle versus
what's actually coming out
of the brain?
ROHAN DIXIT: Sure.
So EEG has been studied for
like maybe like 100 years now.
And that is a problem that
every EEG study runs into.
And so there's kind
of a whole suite
of just standard techniques
to get rid of muscle artifact.
It looks a lot different
than brainwave activity
in terms of the
frequency response
and also the amplitude
of the signal.
So, in general,
people build in what
are called artifact
reject algorithms,
just muscle basically signal
rejection that kind of tries
to see if there is in fact
forehead muscle activity or eye
blinks or whatever
and reject them.
So that's one way
to do it, another
is-- I think that's probably
a good enough answer.
There's a ton there actually
in terms of the algorithms that
are used to do that.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
--what we can expect from
consumer based hardware.
Like, you mentioned
the NeuroSky sensors.
Can we actually get an
interesting signal from that
or do we have to go with
something much more fancy?
ROHAN DIXIT: That is a
great question and something
that we've struggled with a lot.
So the NeuroSky is probably
the cheapest EEG device
that's ever been released.
It's a single sensor.
And it's pretty noisy.
I mean, coming from
a research background
where we use higher quality
research grade rather
than clinical grade EEG, the
signal is almost night and day.
To get any kind of useful
signal out of for example
a NeuroSky is an incredible
feat of signal processing
and machine learning.
And we're helped by the fact
that in meditation usually
your eyes are closed
and you're pretty still.
So basically what
we have found is
a kind of subset of
what you can measure
in terms of brain
activity and an activity
that allows you to
do that pretty well
and get a relatively
good signal.
There's a device
coming out pretty soon
called the Muse which I
think is just now fulfilling
their pre-orders.
And that's a much more
high quality device.
I think it's five sensors
or six rather than just one.
But I think for at least for
the foreseeable short term
future, a lot of
these consumer grade
EEG devices are
going to be much less
high quality than your passive
electrode kind of clinical EEG.
All right.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]